Tune in to Mindy Mindy.
This is pointing that way.
Now it works. It was orange. Orange is
not good. Well, in this case, anyways,
hello and welcome all you fine,
beautiful people. It's so happy to see
you all. Happy Father's Day to anybody
who's filling a father role, however
that may come to your life. Um, embrace
the day. Enjoy it. I hope you got a good
one. Um, a couple of announcements
before we start.
There is an endeavor to build a
wheelchair ramp later this year with a
group of fine folk who know how to do
that. I don't know how to do it, but I
did sign up to do it. So, I'm looking
forward to hammering and nailing things
and um doing something good for
somebody. So, I would encourage you to
check that out with the QR code. Um,
also uh Summerama is right around the
corner. Woohoo. I think you got two
weeks. two weeks. Two weeks. So, uh, get
in contact with that if you want your
kids to have a good time on a Saturday
of June 28th and leave them here and let
Maggie and her amazing team just take
care of them and you get some time off.
Um, I highly encourage that. Um,
after that,
I think that is all for the moment
announcement wise. So, uh, we'll settle
into some worship space. And now I'm
going to have to enter a code.
and get that
we exit the kingdom of noise, hurry and
productivity.
Now we enter the kingdom of silence,
stillness and simplicity.
Sacred space, a place for prayer,
worship and adoration. A place to behold
Christ, revelation of God, heartbeat of
creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to
find you, to mend your heart. May we all
come home.
All right, if you guys will stand with
us, we're going to start with a very old
song um that you may recognize from from
a few years back. It's called God of
This City. And as uh as I was scrolling
through my Instagram feed this morning
and seeing just the protests that are
going on and the different political
moves that are happening and so many
voices saying so many different things
right now, it can be easy to feel a
little lost in in the chaos of like what
to pay attention to like what is um
where where do we put our focus as like
the people of God? And one place that I
feel like God is always calling us
towards is to be hope. Is to offer hope
and believe that there is good that God
is wanting to do here in our world in us
and through us. So as we sing these
lyrics, if they're new to you or if
they're familiar from the past, let's
embody them with a spirit of hopefulness
of what God can continue to do here
right around us.
You're the city.
You're the king of these people. You're
the Lord of this nation.
You are
You're the light in this darkness.
You're the hope to the hopeless.
You're the peace to the restless.
You are
There is no one like our God.
Greater things have yet to come. Greater
things still to be done in this.
Gater things are yet to come. Gater
things are still to be done in this
city.
[Music]
You're the God of this city.
You're the king of these people. You're
the Lord of this nation.
You are
You're the light in this darkness.
You're the hope to the hopeless. You're
the king to the restless.
You are.
There is no one like our God.
Gater things have yet to come. Gater
things are still to be done in this
city.
Gater things are yet to come. Greater
things are still to be done in this.
Gater things are yet to come. Gater
things are still turning on him.
And there is no one like our God.
There is no one like you, God.
There is no one like our God.
Gater things have yet to come. Greater
things are still to be done in this
city.
Greater things are yet to come. Greater
things are still to be done.
We believe we believe in you, God. Gater
things are yet to come. Gater things
still to be done in this city.
[Music]
Gater things are yet to come. Gater
things are still to be done.
[Music]
Greater things.
All right, kiddos. You guys are
dismissed to go to your classes with
your teachers. They'll meet you over
here by the doors.
[Music]
We all have a good night together. We'll
see you after.
And we are going to transition into the
prayers of the people. So, if you guys
would follow along on the screens with
the parts in red and read those aloud
with us and then um use this space to
offer up what you might be carrying
heavy tonight.
Jesus, for this city of Saxi, Texas, and
for every city and community and all who
live in them. We pray to you for the
good earth that you have given us, and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it.
We pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and the orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you, Lord. We know that you love
us and that you hear us. So we lift
these names and situations up to you.
[Music]
For the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts, we pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace and a deep sense
of your presence. Amen.
[Music]
How can I respond?
How can I respond
to the love?
[Music]
I don't have much.
I don't have much, but I have a heart
that beats for you. I have a heart that
beats for you.
[Music]
Every
part of me
wants to love you like you love me.
My Lord,
I don't have much.
I don't have much, but I have a heart
that beats for you. I have a heart that
beats for you. I don't have much.
I don't have much, but I have a heart
that beats for you. I have a heart that
beats for you. I have a heart that beats
for you. I have a heart that beats for
you. I have a heart that beats for you.
I have a heart that beats for you. I
have a life I'll give to you. I have a
life I'll give to you. I have a life
I'll give to you. I have a life I'll
give to you. I have a heart that beats
for you. I have a heart that beats for
you. I have a heart that beats for you.
I have a heart that beats for you.
I don't have
[Music]
a heart that beats for you. I have a
heart that beats for you.
I don't have
a heart that beats for you. I have a
heart that beats for you.
[Music]
We love you
and we'll never stop
[Music]
without you.
Jesus,
we love you
and we can't get enough.
All this is for you, Jesus.
We love you.
We'll never stop. We can't live without
you,
Jesus.
We love you,
and we can't get enough.
All this is for you, Jesus.
[Applause]
Jesus.
[Music]
[Applause]
When you walk into the room,
everything changes
and darkness starts to tremble at the
light that you bring. When you walk into
the room,
every heart starts burning. And nothing
matters more than just to sit here at
your feet and worship you.
We worship you.
When you walk into the room,
sickness starts to vanish. Every
hopeless situation
ceases to exist. When you walk into the
room, the dead begin to rise. Cuz there
is resurrection life in all you do.
[Music]
[Applause]
We love you.
We'll never stop. We can't live without
you, Jesus.
We love you
and we can't get enough.
All this is for you. Jesus.
[Applause]
Jesus.
Oh
Our
[Music]
hearts are yours. We want you.
We want you
to come and consume.
We give you permission. Our hearts are
yours. We want you.
We want you
to come and consume God. All we are. We
give you permission. Our hearts are
yours. We want you.
We want you
to come and consume, God. Oh, we are to
give you permission. Our hearts are
yours. We want you.
We want you.
We love you.
We'll never stop. We can't live without
you, Jesus.
We love you
and we can't get enough.
All this is for you, Jesus.
and the star
to Jesus.
[Applause]
We can't get enough.
All this is for you, Jesus.
Jesus.
[Music]
Oh my Jesus.
Jesus.
God, I do pray that we would find you in
the midst of our hopeless situations.
that where we are experiencing death and
darkness
that your spirit would begin to rise up
within us and create life and light
God in our culture right now. Would we
be people of light and life?
Would we be people of hope?
[Music]
And God, would you teach us to keep
hoping and keep trusting a God who is
not done?
A God who is for us.
[Music]
A God who's on the side of widows and
orphans and immigrants and the
marginalized.
[Music]
God, would we find the places where
we're where you're working and would we
show up?
Would we bring your love
and would it begin to transform us,
transform our lives,
our families,
our relationships, and our world.
God, do your work in our hearts.
We love you
and we want more of you, Jesus.
It's in your name we pray. Amen.
[Music]
All right. Would you turn to the person
beside you and say, "The peace of Christ
be with you.
Well, grace and peace.
It's uh good to be with you all yet
again another Sunday. And uh as always,
that that welcome includes those join us
online. Uh don't forget your communion
elements for later in the service. You
can join in with us on that. And uh
yeah, and also anyone here who is new, I
think it's mostly folks who've been
here.
Um yeah, glad to glad to be with you
all. So, um, oh, also of course, happy
Father's Day yet again, all you dads.
And, um, and also happy Pride. Happy
Pride Month. And hey, shout out anyone
able to go to Pride booth. Yesterday,
we're just the Pride event, but also of
course we had the booth and everything.
Big thank you to Allison and others who
were able to like help actually, you
know, kind of be there to be part of our
booth and all that. And, uh, I know it
was a meaningful, super meaningful time.
It's our presence there always matters,
you know what I mean? Like it can be
kind of hit and miss. Some years we'll
have like tons of connections and then
and even some visitors and then other
times we won't, you know, but it's
always important, I think, for churches
just to be there as a presence, even for
just people who walk by and see churches
representing Christ and saying
sorry and we got this wrong and now we
want to get it right and you know, love
on folks and all that. So really really
matters. Um so yeah, big thank you to
all you who were able to to do that. So,
um, let's see. We are in part six in our
series. Uh, next week will be the last
message in the series. Um, we'll be
talking about the arts kind of next
week. Uh, this week, um, well, let me
talk a little bit about the series. I
think most you've been here, but just a
reminder. So, it's the the series is
titled Enchanted: Reclaiming Sacred
Ground and Disenchanted World. And uh we
just been kind of reflecting on the
secular what it means to kind of have
this uh to kind of live in a somewhat
you know secular nation and uh a place
where you know religion and such is sort
of pushed off to the private sphere and
uh and and kind of plays sort of a
backseat role and and kind of been
talking about some of the implications
of that. you know what is it what does
it mean to um live in this kind of
country um really I mean honestly this
kind of world where I mean since the
west has sort of become so dominant
influential you know globally uh this is
kind of the the the mood and u you know
it's really kind of uh I mean I think of
like the way tech for example you know
the titans of tech now have way more
influence than say like the pope you
know um and that's just these are these
kind of uh you know big shifts that have
happened the last few hundred years. And
so we've kind of just been reflecting on
well what does that mean you know for us
as as Christians. So um the title of my
message this week is seeing beyond the
secular and Christian nationalism. So
we're talking talking politics. We did
this uh leading up to the election back.
We did a Jesus and politics series. Um,
and so I've kind of had more time to
keep reflecting on it because I I
honestly think this is like a big it's a
big old topic. And um you know really I
think this question of kind of how
Christians should engage politically
is like it's not only is it deeply
important but it's also a conundrum
because of the history you know because
of how we various ways we've tried to do
that and we've had a lot of like
literally thousands of years to try
different ways and it just feels like
there's pitfalls everywhere. like you on
the one hand you're it's easy to kind of
fall into this sort of total handsoff
kind of apolitical you know hey I just
only want to be spiritual and talk about
you know heaven and Christ and the
spiritual life and you kind of can slip
into that mode but then you kind of
react to that and then you can start
sliding into kind of a deeply Christian
nationalist you know um yeah kind of
mode so it's it's just it's really
tricky trying to kind of find the way so
this this sermon in a lot of ways it's
me um I'll be kind of processing some of
this uh the journey that I've been on
kind of thinking some of this through.
Um I'll start by making the best
possible argument I can for Christian
nationalism um as an attempt to steelman
that position as opposed to straw man
it. I think it's really easy in this
political climate to straw man. This is
kind of just human tendency anyway. You
know, we kind of straw man the the
positions that we don't hold. we just
sort of set up like a character of it
and then knock it down and say like look
this other position is genius of course
because that's so stupid you know and uh
but then there's like questions
lingering in the back of our mind about
it you know why is why does that
continue to be so alluring for people
you know there's I think there's very
good reasons why that is and we need to
really think those through and wrestle
and grapple with them so we can um kind
of think of like okay what might a
better way forward be so that's kind of
where we'll be going in the message um
so our scripture is from Jere Jeremiah
chapter 29. And uh just for some context
um well let me read verse one because it
sets up some of this. Says this is the
text of the letter that the prophet
Jeremiah sent from Jerusalem to the
surviving elders among the exiles and to
the priests and the prophets and all the
other people that Nebuchadnezzar had
carried into exile from Jerusalem to
Babylon. So we know some of your like
biblical history 586 BC Babylon comes in
conquers Jerusalem conquers the the
Jewish kind of nation there and it's a
catastrophe like national psychological
this is the people of God you know like
they really believe like God's on their
side and going to absolutely protect
them like yeah maybe at the fringes will
be beaten back but like Jerusalem will
never fall it is the holy city literally
has the temple like in God's presence
was believed to literally be there in
the temple like there's no way this
falls, this changes. No way.
And then it did. And it was just like
like what does this mean? So, and not
only that, then a a big chunk of the
people are carried off to Babylon. So
they're not even living there, you know,
like now or in their hometown like now
they're they're in a foreigners in a
foreign land and they're trying to
figure out what are they going to do?
How are they going to put their life
back together? And this is where the
political side comes in. How are they to
relate to this nation now? They're it's
like, are we against it? Because they're
like, this is Babylon. This is pagan.
This is everything we're, you know, not
for. So, are we like are we against this
or do we just kind of pull back and like
kind of do our little holy huddle thing
and like not really get involved with
people like or some some middle or do we
just become good Babylonians,
you know, kind of give up the ways and
just, you know, acquies and so that
that's kind of what they're wrestling
with. So, keep some of those options in
mind as we go through this message. um
like many of the sermons in this series,
this is a weird message and that I'm not
like doing a lot of scripture and such,
but keep that kind of background um in
mind. So, verse four continues, "This is
what the Lord Almighty, the God of
Israel, says to all those I carried into
exile," which is an interesting little
turn phrase there that I carried into
exile from Jerusalem to Babylon. This is
the word. Now, this is what the Lord
says. Build houses and settle down,
plant gardens, and eat what they
produce. Marry and have sons and
daughters. Find wives for your sons and
give your daughters in marriage so that
they too may have sons and daughters.
Increase in number there. Do not
decrease. This is the the key verse.
Verse 7. Also seek the peace and
prosperity of the city to which I have
carried you into exile. Pray to the Lord
for it because if it prospers, you too
will prosper.
So,
okay. So, what's missing in kind of
modern
politics
uh in the United States from a a more
kind of politically um
kind of conservative Christian
uh viewpoint? Well, in his book After
Virtue, I've quoted um Alistair McIntyre
a few times in this series. This book I
think is incredibly important. Uh so he
kind of charts the way that the the
modern kind of western political
tradition by uh as we've been talking
about kind of by bracketing out, you
know, religion and uh kind of all god
talk and the classically religious
stories that tell us who we are and why
we're here and what the good is and you
know how we ought to bring our own lives
into alignment with that vision, right?
that when you kind of bracket all that
out and you say like, well, okay, well,
that is for the that's for the private
sphere. That's for that's you and your
little heart. You know, you can believe
whatever you want to believe in. Uh just
don't bring that into the the public
sphere.
um that McIntyre charts the way that
once we did that
we really started to quickly lose our
way and not just our way kind of like in
as individuals but really our kind of
collective social and political u way
precisely because it's religion that
gives us a social kind of vision of what
the good is uh by the good I'm thinking
honestly like this some of that language
is from Plato but Plato he never really
defined it was it's something like a
kind of vision of God or you know what's
the highest most important
value or beauty or goodness you can
imagine you know what it's almost you
want to keep it a little vague but but
you want to keep aiming for it talking
about it dreaming about it you know
trying to articulate it uh because it
kind of keeps you moving towards it
right So uh so what happens is right
it's religion that gives us that vision
and so what happens though when you cut
yourself off from that vision in essence
and you say like no no no no um we don't
really have that we're not really about
that what what do you do well I'd say
this is why in the modern west um we're
all about freedom of what freedom of
choice
right because in essence we have no
shared vision of what the good is.
And so
what is the good? U
whatever you think you know I mean like
in essence it's it's kind of different
you know for everyone that that kind of
is our vision of the the highest good.
So kind of in essence you know we don't
really know what it is but you as an
individual you have a choice about um
you know how you live. So one person
chooses to spend their life, you know,
on behalf of like the poor and the
marginalized and we say, "Well, that's
good. That's good for you."
You know, that's so good for you. I'm so
glad you do that. Another person spend,
you know, chooses their life making as
much money as possible and we're like,
"Well, that's good for you." You know,
and another person, I don't know, spends
their life playing video games in the
basement or something, you know, and
it's like, well, that's good for them,
you know? So, we don't that's can you
kind of see where where this goes,
right? All those are kind of equally
good from the perspective of the kind of
western political tradition. So you can
you can see some of the uh the issues
that are already going to surface here
right that basically this totally
undermines any vision of what we might
call the common good.
Like even that phrase I feel cheesy
saying it you know like the common good.
like I don't when was the last time you
heard anyone like this is about the
common good or even if a politician were
to kind of you know use that phrase or
something the question would be what do
they mean?
What are they talking about in a kind of
modern secular individualistic society
where our highest good is whatever we
choose as long as it doesn't hinder
someone else's vision of the good,
right? And so it becomes sort of
meaningless, right? because it's been
cut off from the kind of broader
religious stories and theology and
scriptures and community and practices
that can give rise to it in the first
place. Uh this would be some of the
critique as well of kind of how in the
modern world we are all about values
right what's your values what are their
values and even like organizationally we
have values and our values are different
from their values and even at an
individual level what values do you
value and what values do you value and
what are your val you right but um
notice they're at least in the kind of
modern west they're sort of free
floating
it's just bunch of random words.
Does that make sense? Like why? Cuz
they're now like initially those words
really used to mean something and even
had the certain hierarchies and such to
them because they were part of a broader
tradition stories and religion and such
that kind of gave them their meaning.
But now we just kind of have the words
sort of free free floating out there. So
in other words, you can have, you know,
like critiques of religion,
Christianity, Buddhism, Islam, whatever.
Um, however, what what they do have is a
certain vision of like social
flourishing.
And um
there is a there there's a common good
there. But in the secular west, we've
really cut ourselves off from those
religious stories, right? Our our vision
of the common good has faded.
This is what more conservative
Christians have seen.
And and I think there's there's I think
it's there's a lot of truth there. And I
think this is where more progressive
Christians have tended to be a bit more
naive on this point. In other words, who
is more comfortable kind of with the the
secular? I mean, it's definitely if you
think conservative Christians,
progressive Christians. It's definitely
progressives, right? Who are like a
little more comfy with the secular
tradition, right? It's progressive
Christians um who I would say kind of
flirt more with these ways of thinking
and being. Like for example, it's often
progressive Christians who say things
like, you know, well look Brett, I
really um I really appreciate so much
about the Christian tradition. Um I I
love the the works of mercy. Oh, I
really appreciate the care for the poor,
the language from the prophets about
social justice, the way Christ valued
and loved the lowly, the weak, and the
marginalized.
I really I like all that. I think that's
very beautiful and compelling.
I just don't want all the rest.
Does that make sense? like I just died.
All the God talk and the Christ and
being, you know, maybe God or rising the
dead and just like I just and all the
church and community and spiritual
practices like all that. I just don't
know about that. In essence, I just kind
of want to leave Christianity behind,
but I do want to retain Christian social
teaching and its vision of the common
good. It's a little bit like uprooting a
plant from the soil
and then really hoping it continues to
flourish and then being quite surprised
when it's like well it's really
withering you know like yes
so you can kind of see the naivity there
right naivity this is like where I think
it's this is where more conservative
folks have seen this more clearly right
I think they've said like yeah that's
like that's not how it works the
tradition tradition as a whole helps to
nurture those things that you love. So
if you undermine or you end up leaving
the tradition as a whole behind well now
your values are just free floating and
maybe you carry them on for a while just
out of you know it's almost the momentum
of living and it's like well I was
raised this way just kind of how I'll
keep living you know but it's way less
likely that your kids will or the next
generation the generation after that you
know you can see where it's a sort of a
slow decay and decline because your
values no longer make sense right you've
no longer got the context that made them
sensical in the first place. So, kind of
to to sum it up, conservatives, I think,
would say, look, a political community
must have some generally accepted vision
of what the good is. We must be united
in our vision of what flourishing looks
like. However, if we don't if we don't
have a generally agreed upon vision of
that, well, now we have no basis for
what virtue for what the good life
actually is. Because a good life is that
which is lived in alignment with your
vision of what? The good, right? And God
and such. So if you don't have that
shared vision, you don't have a
political community. And you certainly
can't have any sane conversations where
you attempt to persuade one another and
say, "Well, isn't that quite a little
off? And isn't this more with the good?"
And they're like, "Oh, that makes
sense." You know, no, you can't really
have those conversations anymore because
you're speaking totally different moral
languages. You're not a people. You're a
mob.
That's the best argument I can make. I
mean, it's not bad. Like, bad argument,
you know what I mean? Like, um, the
thing to notice there, that is that's
the roots of Christian nationalism.
Like, that's the that's what's giving it
kind of energy in life. Even if people
out on the streets can't quite
articulate it that clearly. I'm not
saying you go on social media and see
someone give that kind of clear of a
synthesis like, "Yes, it's about my
vision of the good." But, you know, but
it's it's it's in people's anxiety
over young folks and
moral boundaries and what's going on? Do
we even care about the good anymore? You
know, it's it's you can kind of feel it
coming out um in those ways. And so, I,
you know, I I'm sympathetic to this. I
see um the logic in it. Um, I'm
sympathetic to its longing for people to
have a kind of shared vision of God and
thus of the good and therefore of the
common good and what a virtuous and good
life looks like maybe at an individual
level. Um, I I'm sympathetic to that.
So, what's the what's the problem with
this? Well,
here's the thing. I'd say it's one of
those ideas that in theory it makes like
perfect sense,
you know, like, hey, wouldn't it be
great if we could just all be on the
same page and pulling in the same
direction? Wouldn't that be wow, that
would be great? Uh, it would it would be
great. However,
uh as we've tried to implement that
throughout history, it turns into a
total freaking disaster.
Like for those wondering, you know, has
anything like this been tried?
[Laughter]
Yes. Yes. Um it has. Um in the Christian
world, it was called Christendom, right?
A whole marriage of church and the
state, right? Church and religion and
government. Um and the Christian
religion um yeah tried this experiment
and honestly it just uh it did not go so
well to put it mildly um in essence if
you had to kind of sum it up real
shortly you know I'd say the problem was
like in essence there's just a
difference between um inviting people
into a certain vision of like God and
the good and what a beautiful life could
be and there's a total difference
between inviting people into
and like forcing people into that like
making that the law of the land and if
you don't get on the same pay you know
what I mean like you can can you see
where this so quick like again in theory
it's sounds genius you know um
but in in practice it it gets sideways
and uh and so historically these types
of religious political projects um and
really on both the political left and
the right uh basically anywhere where
people said, "Okay, um, look, this is
the vision of the good. That's
establishing us as a political community
and
you don't agree."
And so where did that go? you know,
well, at best what it turns into is a
kind of marginalization. You know what I
mean? At best, it's like, okay, well,
you're on the edges and you maybe don't
have the same voting rights as the
people who are like the right religion
or the right ethnic, you're the right,
you know, I mean, at best it's that. Uh,
or maybe like, oh, you have to leave,
you have to leave the nation state, you
have to leave this country, you're no
longer, you know, at best it's that. At
worst, of course, it's like genocidal
and um heretic burning and you know, I
mean, it's it's all of that u total
mess. And so, um,
yeah, to kind of put the the the the
question, well, the way I heard one
podcaster put it, he's said, uh, anytime
there's someone with like a certain
political vision and it's it's almost
utopia, you know, it's like, yes, I know
how we should be, and I know what it
should look like, and I if we could just
all get on the same page, and the
podcaster said, I always ask that
person, uh, okay, well, that's a very
beautiful vision there, but I do have to
ask, how many people have to die in
order for your utopia to be established?
You know, that's that's why the church
is haunted. That's why I say this has
been like this has bedeled the church
throughout the centuries. This is what
we're wrestling with
is that because that's that's the
history. People have died over this
stuff. And uh to kind of put it in
Christian terms, we might say, how many
people have to die in order for everyone
in America to be an act Christian so
that your vision of the kingdom of the
God who is love can finally be
established?
you know, Lord have mercy.
Um, now to be clear, it's not like only
Christianity has ever made this mistake,
you know, like no, no, no, of course
not. As we kind of charted um back a few
sermons ago about the way kind of Nazism
and Marxism and stuff, even those have
these sort of religious impulses in
them, you know, certain visions, big
grand meta narratives that can be
neither proven nor disproven, but you
kind of buy them because it compels you
with this kind of vision and, you know,
that's it's religion, you know. So
Germany had its its little uh not little
its absolute disaster of Nazism. Russia
had Marxism. Uh the Islamic State is of
course doing similar things around the
world. Uh even many Jewish people um
particularly those on the political
left. Some of you know I've been in like
a year-long reading project. It's going
on way too long. But trying to wrestle
with everything that's going on over in
the Middle East and Israel and all that
trying to understand it, you know. And
uh I read one of the books I read was
this series of essays by people from the
political left in Israel. And you can
feel their agony as they're honestly
they're wrestling with a lot of the
things we're we're talking about. Um
because
I mean well you can see right what
happens with the Jewish state in their
fight against the Palestinians, right?
In essence it's the same thing. We're
we're going to establish a nation state
but it's going to have a religious twist
on it. And so we need to maintain a
majority for sure. At the very least, we
have to maintain a majority to keep
power, but also we really need the
people in power to be of the right
tradition. You know, the the right at
least at the very least of Judaism in
general. And uh so you know what happens
when um there's hundreds of thousands if
not millions of people in that same area
who aren't on board with that religious
tradition. What do you do?
Well, you can see if follow the news
like where that where that goes. It's a
it's an absolute disaster.
So, um, you know, even heck, even here
in Sax, Texas,
come September,
just might have the Ten Commandments in
classrooms.
And that's a fir it's a it's a it's like
a first step, you know, I mean, you
might say, "Oh, it's just the Ten
Commandments, and don't people need, you
know, this kind of some moral training
or something?" But you can see where
that where that's going, right? It's
it's just the the kind of first crack in
the dam and hopefully the federal
government will end up overwriting that.
Um but still the response from certain
Christian conservatives, right, is that
well but Christianity was in many ways
still is foundational. Um well, let's
just go back in history. It was
foundational to the people of this
country, right? To the folks coming over
on the Mayflower and all those like
wasn't it weren't they all Christians?
And to that I would say like well yes
like yeah of course uh of course most of
the people who came to America were
Christians but guess why they came here?
Oh remember some of that some of that
history they were Christians fleeing
what?
Christendom.
You say well how could this be? Why on
earth would Christians flee
christryendom? Well, see, that's the
trick when you establish, you know, it's
got to be the right kind of Christians.
You know what I mean? Like it's it's
maybe we think, well, those
Pentecostals, you know, they don't fit
or, oh, those Baptists or those, you
know, whatever it ends up being if it
you can see where you end up having to
winnow it down to get more clear and get
everyone on the same page. You know what
I mean? Um, I mean, I just think if
there were kind of a religious theocracy
kind of that made a huge sweeping change
in America, like I mean, we're a
Christian church, would we be accepted?
I don't think so.
So, you can see where this it just it
just never ends. So, for this reason, I
I do I get it. I get where my more
conservative Christian siblings are
coming from on this, but no, no, no. I
don't I don't believe that a a marriage
between church and state is the right
way to go. Um I don't believe that us
trying to set up the kingdom of heaven
on earth by creating a religious
theocracy is the way to go. So where on
earth do we go from here? Well, um, in
light of everything we just covered, um,
I'll I'll just kind of go out on a limb
and say, well, I do think that
representative governments that provide
political institutions where no one is
barred from participating based on their
religious belief or ethnicity or sexual
orientation or gender, you know, and so
on and so on. Um, I would say that is
the least worst political system humans
have come up with. Maybe that's not a
glowing endorsement, but uh it's a
little bit as as Winston Churchill
famously said, "Democracy is the worst
form of government except for all those
other forms that have been tried from
time to time."
In other words, I understand that it it
lends itself to all of the criticisms I
leveled against it in the first part of
my sermon. I I really do think a lot of
those hold like a lot of water. Like I
get it. Yes. that um like no sing we
have no single shared vision of the
good. That's true. I get it that we are
struggling as a country and in many ways
as a world to kind of make any sense of
what the common good even means anymore.
I think our values for consumerism and
individualism
which I would really lie pretty much at
the feet of of at least consumerism
certainly lies at the feet of capitalism
you know for all of the amazing good and
productivity and such it's created. also
um I think started to erode any sort of
healthy political um engagement by the
day, right? You know, and it's often
been said something like, you know,
we're no longer citizens, we're
consumers, and you know, and so on. I
think that that there's a lot of sense
there. So, yes, all that is true.
However, even knowing all of that, I
don't believe Christians in this country
should try to grab political power and
try to turn it into a so-called
Christian nation. Right? That's only to
fall into all of the problems of
Christian history. Christendom was a
failure. And it's really only those who
are either ignorant of that history or
just hungry for power, you know, who
want to wield it again, who are
interested in resurrecting all that. So,
no, no, no. We can't go that road. I
think what we need is a new we need a
new imagination. We need a new
imagination for who the church is called
to be um in relation to the nation state
and
for some these metaphors I'm about to
kind of give you um they may sound a
little too weak you know um but but
honestly they are they're weak on
purpose right why because a Christ came
among us uh in that posture of kind of
meekness and loneliness right not trying
to get all the power he could and
establish himself as top dog and then
make everyone you know but uh that's one
reason but also second as we've been
talking about because these metaphors
are intentionally
like trying not to usher in a new
Christristendom and and push people in
that, you know, direction. So that's why
the metaphors are weak. So So here's a
we'll call them new metaphors for a
politically and socially engaged church.
I'll just run through these real uh
first church as servant.
We're here to serve the common good, to
work for the good of the city, the
state, the country Christ has placed us
in while rejecting all forms of
triumphalism.
Think back to Jeremiah 29:7. God's
placed them there in Babylon. Placed
them in that in that city didn't say,
"Yeah, get in there and grab all the
power and ch change everyone." You know,
it's no, no, it's it's work for the good
of the city. Serve, be your presence
there.
Uh second church as pilgrim. We're
journeying through this world and trying
to bestow as much love, dignity, and
compassion on others as we can. Not
trying to grab all the power that we
can. Third, church. As prophet, we align
ourselves nonviolently with liberating
social movements for the politically and
socially marginalized and oppressed. You
think of what's a what's a prophet? A
prophet um a prophet's not the king,
right? A prophet is like the the moral
conscience to the king. I think this is
the the church is much better in the
role of prophet and annoying gadfly,
you know, much better in that role than
trying to take on play king and prophet
at the same time. It's just it just as
we talked about, it just gets all all
wonky. Um, fourth church as evangelist.
We're called to witness to and serve
both our country and the broader world
in the name of Jesus Christ. Again, not
to conquer or dominate them. You can see
where that that's back to that
invitational idea, right? You can invite
people into a vision of the good. You
can welcome and and kind of um try to
make it as beautiful and compelling as
you can. That is different than like
forcing and coercing. Um, fifth and
finally, churches partner.
This is you really lose this in
Christendom. We're actually called to
dialogue with and create friendships
across political, ethnic, cultural, and
religious divides. Boy, does our world
need this. Seeking common ground as we
together create a more humane world.
So in short, I don't think the way
Christians can best be political is by a
trying to usher in a new Christendom or
b losing our Christian identity by
adopting more secular ways of thinking
and being. In essence, I believe the
United States desperately needs people
who still have some clarity and some
vision of what the good actually is.
like it desperately needs people formed
in Christian disciplehip.
People for whom forgiveness is a way of
life. People for whom learning to love
even our enemies is a way of life.
People who have a patience and a
tenderheartedness formed by prayer and
silence.
people who care about the poor and the
common good because Jesus told us to and
because we've seen the beauty of living
in this way. Christians who actually
give a damn for those on the margins
like immigrants, LGBTQ folks, and ethnic
minorities.
In short, both conservative Christians
with their longing for a new Christendom
and more secular folks with their vision
of the highest good simply being the
choice to live how I want. I think these
are moral, social, and political dead
ends. And because of this, I really do
believe this like down to my toes.
Progressive Christians are uniquely
situated.
If we can hold back from deconstructing
our entire Christian heritage in
theology to utter pieces, which is big
if, but if we can do that, I really
think we're uniquely situated to be a
moral conscience and a beautiful and
compelling voice for political good in
this country.
That's all I got. In the name of the
Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit.
Amen.
So on the night Jesus was betrayed, he
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held up a loaf of
bread. He broke it. And he said, "This
is my body. It's broken for you. He held
up the cup of wine. He said, "This is my
blood. It's shed for you. Whenever you
eat this bread, whenever you drink this
cup, remember me."
So, as we come forward together, may we
come forward as one body, one people.
Even in our differences, but still some
some conception of what the good is,
Christ himself. we love and and seek to
bring our own lives and heart into
alignment with who he is and his great
love. So we'll just go rowby row form a
line right here in the middle and
practice an open table. So all of you
are welcome uh to participate and the
red is wine, white is grape juice and
you can just partake whenever however
you'd like. Some folks like to come and
you some take right away. However you
want to do it you can do that. So this
is the table not of the church
but of the Lord and it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more. So God
come you who have much faith and you who
have little. You who have been here
often and you have not been here long.
You who have tried to follow and you who
have failed. Come. Come because it's the
Lord Jesus himself who invites you and
it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here. Come to
the table.
[Music]
Um, just got put on the spot here a
little bit. Um,
anyways, I'll say something to you dads
out there. Um,
it's not easy being a dad. Um,
we do a lot behind the scenes.
Um, we provide,
we screw it up,
we get angry,
and we bear a lot of weight
on our shoulders.
Um,
and I can think of my dad,
you know, and realize that he was a
human just trying to do his best.
Um,
and he didn't always do a good job. And
I was pretty mad at him on several
occasions.
Um, held unforgiveness in my heart
towards him for many years.
But I let that go
because God forgave me.
And who am I to hold back my
forgiveness?
[Music]
Regardless of where you are with your
dad
um or not, that's a hard thought to even
think about. Just remember there's a
good God
and there's friends and people who care
about you.
We're not perfect, especially our dads.
They're not perfect, but they
are humans whether they tried or not
to be there.
[Music]
Yeah. So, we'll close out with this last
song
and uh
be blessed today as you go from here.
You guys go ahead and stand with us.
[Music]
You're the God of this city.
You're the king of these people.
You're the Lord of this nation.
You are
You're the light in this darkness.
You're the hope to the hopeless.
You're the peace to the restless.
You are
There is no one like our God.
Greater things of yet to come. Gater
things are still to be done in this
city.
Gater things are yet to come. Gater
things are still to be done in this
city.
[Music]
You're the God of this city.
You're the king of these people.
You're the Lord of this nation.
You are
You're the light in this darkness.
You're the hope to the hopeless.
You're the peace to the restless.
You are
You are There is no one like our God.
There is no one like our God.
[Music]
Gater things are yet to come. Gater
things are still to be done in this
city.
Gater things are yet to come. Gater
things still to be done in this city.
[Music]
Gater things are yet to come. Gater
things are still to be done here.
[Music]
Thank you so much for joining us
tonight. whether you're a first- time
visitor or you've been here quite a bit.
Um, it's good to see you tonight. Um, a
couple of things before we go. Um, if
you've been coming here for a while and
you're not involved in a ministry team,
now is a great time to try to figure
that out possibly for you. Um, it can be
really rewarding. even if it's just
standing up here talking to y'all or
it's working with kids or being
absolutely silent in the back of the
tech booth and barely ever being noticed
where they do great things back there.
Um if something like that appeals to
you, um there's an opportunity to do
that um with the QR code that you will
find on the screen. Also, um, if this is
your church home and you feel compelled
or desire to support the ministry here,
you can do that via the QR code or you
can make a donation at the small table
on your way out. Um,
so as we end tonight, let me send you
off with a benediction for your week.
You are a child of God.
You are a child of God. This is true on
your best day and it's true on your
worst day.
So as you go into your week ahead with
yet to be determined highs and lows and
everything in between,
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved.
You are worthy and you are accepted just
as you are.
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with. Be blessed.
We'll see you here next Sunday.
There is no like our God.
There is no one like you, God.
No one like you. There is no one like
our God.
you, God.
Greater things are yet to come. Greater
things are still to be done in this
city.
Greater things are yet to come and
greater things still to be done in this
city.
Greater things are yet to come and
greater things are still to be done
here.
[Music]
Thanks, bro.
I wanted to share